hello welcome to my webinar for
optimizing the extraction of human
microbiome samples
um my name is dominic o'neill i'm the
director for r d
my responsibility is microbiome product
development at kyogen
so just before we start with the
presentation
i'd like to provide the quick legal
disclaimer i'll be talking about
different kaioshin products here
and the products that i show are
intended for molecular biology
applications
not intended for the diagnosis
prevention or treatment of disease
okay then to our agenda i'll have a
brief introduction on microbiome and why
microbiome studies are interesting i'm
sure that you're all very well aware of
this already
and then i will talk about optimal dna
extraction from stool samples with the
cayenne power people approach kit
which we really do believe is the new
gold standard for extracting dna from
soil samples
and then the next point is different
sampling techniques
and automation for the amp power fecal
pro kit
and then the last part of the talk will
wrap up with the
application of this kit to other human
microbiome samples
outside the gut
so the microbiome is of course a
fascinating subject
of study and new insights are being made
consistently
um one of the first major uh projects to
investigate it was of course the human
microbiome project which really
showed the diversity of microbiomes that
lived with us
and in us and on us and and provided the
first insights into
the the depth of additional
biological functions that these
microbiomes provide in the second genome
that we carry
and then also started to eliminate some
of the health effects of it and so
of course it's fascinating to start
looking at
microbiome samples in order to
understand what effect that has
on humans and of course if you're doing
a microbiome experiment it's very
different than simply looking for
a single pathogen so when you're looking
for a microbiome sample
you pretty much have to do sequencing
downstream and you're mostly looking for
answer one of two questions which
organisms are present what is their
relative abundance so if you're looking
at the the community
um that's present and which organisms
may be providing a function within that
community
is on the one side looking at dna if
you're doing bacteria and archaea you're
probably interested in looking at 16s
rdna
or metagenomic we'll also provide you
that information you can get fungal
information off of the its gene
sequencing
viruses through metagenomic sequencing
as well
and all of those are dna-based analysis
methods and they will really tell you
which organisms are present you can get
much more information out than you can
with traditional culture methods and so
on um on the other hand if you're
looking for functions of the community
you may want to look into meta
transcriptomics if you're looking at rna
and messenger rna that's present or if
you're looking at metabolites or protein
characterization you may be going to
looking at metabolomics proteomics
but for the purposes of the talk here
i'm really focusing on
the left-hand side of this chart on
which organisms are present what's their
relative abundance
and primarily around the 16s rrna gene
sequencing
and of course like i said mentioned at
the beginning the entire talk is around
optimization of dna extraction
from human microbiome samples
so the questions are what really matters
when you're trying to do dna isolation
from microbiome analysis and of course
the first point
is that yield is critical the more that
you can get out of your sample
the more analysis that you can do the
higher chance you have of detecting low
abundant species
and you can just simply be more
confident in your results if you really
know that you're extracting all the dna
that's present in your sample
you need to be aware of inhibitors
so especially in stool samples
inhibitors are a major challenge
um there's lots and lots of inhibitory
samples which can
then have a negative impact on your
downstream analysis particularly
considering that most of the
metagenomics or
and 16s analysis is all pcr based
or enzymatic reactions and the
inhibitors that are present in stool
samples
have a very dramatic effect on these
downstream analysis so your prep needs
to be able to handle these
and the last point is that you really
need to lyse efficiently
the microbiome is made up of many
highly diverse species with very diverse
cell walls
and therefore also very different
requirements for breaking them open
um so depending on what you pick for
your lysis you can also bias your prep
very strongly towards certain types of
bacteria or fungus and mis other ones
entirely
and we've found that that this is really
a critical critical point that we've
spent some time on optimizing
so in light of these three points it's
really what we've done
in releasing the power fecal pro dna and
dnz power
soil pro kits so these are second
generation kits
following on from the power fecal and
power soil kits which have become very
standardized for microbiome samples
originally from mobile and now hydrogen
has a second generation that we have
upgraded
in various ways and the upgrades
involved
in adding a new lysis tube
so there's a new lysis matrix that we
have
along with a new lysis chemistry
and the inclusion of this really
improves our yields dramatically
in some cases up to 20-fold i'll show
you some data on that
we streamlined our inhibitor removal
technology
as i mentioned that's also highly
critical and the new irt
is faster removes more inhibitors
providing a better downstream ngspcr
performance
and then the last point is again
associated with these
new powerbeat protubes and the new lysis
chemistry that we've
implemented is that we get a better
lysis of the microbes in the sample more
uniform
and a higher detection of more species
than very um previous so
we really do believe that these pro kits
provide
a new gold standard and give you the
best representation of stool and soil
microbiomes
so as i mentioned the inhibitor removal
is a critical point
and that is shown here the mechanism
that we do it so
all of the kyogen kits which have power
in their name somewhere
so the power soil the power fecal the
power microbiome
any of those kits include irt and irt
is a method of precipitating out
inhibitors during the prep so that you
don't have to do
a post illusion cleanup and separating
the inhibitor very efficiently from the
dna
so that they don't disturb you your
downstream technology
now down below you can see an example of
what happens
when you do a sample prep with irt
on the left with the clear eluit and
without irt
on the right where you have a very
discolored eluot
and the reason for this is that a lot of
the inhibitors that are present in these
kinds of samples
are um molecules that act
very much like dna or are very strongly
associated with dna
and that's of course also why they're so
strongly inhibitory for your downstream
pcr
is because either they'll bind to your
enzyme or they'll bind to your dna
preventing the enzyme from binding it to
it properly
and thereby significantly decrease your
yield or your your signal in the
downstream pcr and that's what's shown
there on the right
the same sample with irt you're getting
cts around 10 to 12
and then once you take that same sample
and run it without irt
in one case you're getting a little bit
of signal around ct
15 16 or so and it goes up very slowly
and the other it's still up in the late
30s so you can have really dramatic
decreases in the performance of your pcr
if you are not able to remove the
inhibitors
out of your sample and that's what's
done with these new kits very
efficiently
but i also mentioned that we have
dramatic increases in yields and here's
an example of that so this is
a test where we took three different
donors
prepped 200 milligrams of stool sample
using some commercially available prep
kits as well as the power fecal pro
kit and you see for two of the samples
for donor a and donor b
you see dramatic increases in the yield
that we get out
so that's where we get the up to 20 fold
increased dna yield
and we're getting with the other kits on
the market we're getting very low yields
for those kits
and then we get very stable yields for
the new kit and donor c
we do get an improvement still with the
new kit but it's not quite as dramatic
as with donors a
and b and that's interesting to know a
little bit about the background here
in that donor a and donor b are both
stool samples from
older individuals and donors see is a
stool sample from a younger individual
this is a test that we did to see
whether or not we could find interesting
differences between
stool samples from older young
individuals and what we found
was that in the general tendency
now this is this is a limited sample
size and of course it's not a
population study or anything but we did
find generally that stool from older
individuals
was more difficult to lyse had a higher
level of inhibitors
and saw a greater improvement with our
new chemistry
than stool from younger individuals
which generally tended to perform fairly
well in almost most methods that we
looked at
as what we see here as well the dramatic
increase comes from these difficult
samples
and keeping that in mind these are the
same three samples
what we see is that when we compare it
in the 16s sequencing
this is again doing the ucp pcr mix from
kaiogen and then 16s
sequencing over illumina and analysis
through clc's genomics
the two difficult samples sample a and
sample b which were the
stool samples from the older individuals
saw a marked increase
in the diversity that we were able to
capture with the pro chemistry so the
blue lines up at the top
where we go from you know
plateauing out at around maybe 300
um species for sample a and around 200
250 species for sample b
in both of the other cases once we use
our pro chemistry
we're able to detect up to 500 different
species
now for the easy-to-life sample sample c
there's very little difference between
the two chemistries so what we're seeing
is that for some of these samples that
are difficult to lyse
we really are able to break open more
and more different bacteria
if they're present than we are able to
do with competitor or with legacy
chemistries
and if you dive down data a little bit
and look at it in particular what we're
seeing is we're finding many more
different species of bifidobacteria
as well as improve detection of archaea
in particular methanol bacteria
and these are difficult to life samples
and so it was very exciting to see that
we're able to find them
at a much higher rate once we use this
new chemistry
and i mentioned as well that you can do
secret uh
fungal sequencing fungal pcr this is
here a fungal pcr look using at a 18s
pan fungal assay and again
moving to our new chemistry to the power
fecal pro chemistry compared to the
legacy chemistry
we see a dramatic improvement in the
extraction of fungal dna
so with the legacy kit we're getting
cycle a ct in the low high 20s
and then with the pro chemistry we're
getting a ct in the high teens
in both cases the exact same sample
being used which means that the pro
chemistry is able to improve our
detection
by approximately 10 cycles compared to
the legacy power fecal
thereby really dramatically improving
sensitivity of fungal detection
right so now i've talked a lot about
just the the sheer
yield and purity and irt improvements
that are possible through the pro
chemistry
but of course there's other challenges
as well for doing
stool dna extractions and one of the
major ones is handling
so as anybody who's done a lot of it
knows that
doing stool extraction weighing out
stool
samples whether they're thawed or
whether you're chipping frozen samples
and trying to
move those things into small b tubes to
do your lysis
it's a very tedious and messy and
unpleasant process
and so in order to streamline this
process we wanted to investigate
the effects of using inoculating loops
to transfer sample rather than trying to
weigh out each sample individually
so we looked at both 10 microliter and
one micrometer inoculating loops
and transferred
the same amount from the same tool
sample either weighing it out to get
exactly 100 milligrams or simply taking
a chip of frozen stool in the 10
milligram the 10 microliter loop with
one microliter loop
and transferring it into the crap and
what we saw was quite interesting
first the yields were much more stable
than we were expecting we were expecting
a higher variation
on yield as we went to the the loops
rather than
into the weighing method but it looks to
be a very stable method to do this
um and the yields coming from the 10
micrometer loop were
surprisingly similar to weighing in 100
milligrams of sample
um in some so for the 100 milligrams of
sample we're getting from
5 to 15 micrograms of dna out
while for the 10 microliter oculating
loop we're getting maybe 5 to 10
and for the one microliter loop of
course it's lower where we're seeing
maybe one to three
because we're transferring simply lower
amounts of material
however even with the one microliter
inoculating loop
we're getting sufficient dna out at the
end that we can do good analysis
and we can see that on the next slide we
of course took the dna that we extracted
here
did a 16s pcr with the ucp multiplex pcr
kit
on the v4 region sequenced it all on the
mysqq
and analyzed it in the microbial
genomics pro suite and
this is the otu tables coming out
of that test where we did eight
individual biological replicates
um so it's eight individual weighings or
transfers with a loop
of the the different donors and did
eight individual um extractions for each
one
individual um sequencing in libraries so
these are these are true biological
replicates and what's really noticeable
is how consistent the method can be so
transferring with the
with the loops is still a highly
consistent way of finding the
the diversity in your sample and the
whether you're using even a one
microliter loop or weighing in 100
milligrams of material
the same information content comes out
we see that here in the otu tables
and we also see it in the diversity plot
so
if we do alpha diversity and beta
diversity
we see no significant difference in the
alpha diversity across the replicates
whether you're weighing in 100
milligrams or using the loops to
transfer
and on the beta diversity plot you see
as well the samples
cluster very strongly based off of the
donor
and not at all based off of the method
which means that we're quite confident
in recommending
that the inoculating loop transfer
method
is a very simple and effective way
to improve the sample transfer portion
of the dna extraction method
and we recommend that for people who are
having trouble with the
the exact weighting out and the amount
of effort that that takes
so but the uh improvements for
your dna extraction are of course not
limited to sample transfer
the sample extraction itself can be
automated
and we've done that in multiple
different ways we have
different instruments for the sample
homogenization from the the standard
vortex adapters which can do up to 24
samples
to the power lizard 24 which can also do
24 samples in a faster method
to the tissue lizard too which can do up
to 96 samples
or even 192 if you do 296 well plates
which are also available as an option
and then to to do the downstream
analysis we of course
optimized the pro kit on the kai eq
where it's the exact same kit that can
just simply be automated on the
classic cube or the cube connect but we
also have separate kits available for
the d and easy power soil pro on the kai
cube ht
or the kai simpson e power fecal pro kit
on the thai symphony
both of these kits the dnc power soil
pro and kai symphony power fecal pro
use the same up front lysis irt
chemistry and they've simply been
adapted for optimizing the extraction on
the instrument downstream
and these enable of course higher
throughput and
more parallel processing of samples if
needed
um and of course it's only useful if you
get the same good results out of the
automated method that you do
from the manual method and that's shown
here for the kai symphony
so we looked at the diversity in
community in stool samples
across four different donors in
triplicate either manually
or on the kaya symphony you can see that
in the otu table
you can see very consistent profiles
coming off of both methods
and a distinct profile coming from each
individual
and that's of course mirrored in the
beta diversity plot
to the right where you can see that the
sample
donor clusters very strongly while the
method seems not to make much difference
so there we're also very pleased with
the performance of the kit on the kaya
symphony
which provides an automated way of doing
up to 96 samples in batches of 24.
four on the kai cube ht which is a 96
well plate based method on a vacuum
instrument
and there again we see exactly the same
results if we use a stool sample
the otu table is on the right in this
case and the alpha diversity on the left
and the alpha diversity you can't even
see the two different charts the two
different colors because they overlay
each other almost precisely
and so we get uh again identical methods
whether we do here in 96 well format on
an automated platform as we do if we do
individual spin columns
so we're very pleased with the
improvements that that offers as well
for the workflow
and then i come to the last part of the
talk where i'd like to mention a little
bit about the use of these kits
for samples other than school all of the
performance data and for stools but
still probably
the most important sample type for
looking at
human microbiome as the majority of the
bacteria that live on us
in us are carried in the gut however
other sample types are of course
interesting provide also distinct
microbiomes
and so we wanted to investigate whether
or not we could use the cayenne power
fecal pro kit for
samples other than stool in order to do
this we had an external service provider
use our kits to extract from vaginal
swabs rectal swabs skin swabs
buckle swabs and saliva all of these
things were processed with the kit
and the extracted dna was then amplified
with the sakaia c16s
its panels sequence on aluminum i seek
and what i'll be showing is all the data
from the v304 region
which we analyze the microbial genomics
pro suite on clc
and we don't have any patient data
or demographic data for these these
samples so what we were really looking
for
was what came out of it was the
sequencing successful
and if it was successful was the
information that came out of it
biologically relevant and that's the
data that i will be showing here
so the first set of samples that i am
showing is saliva and buccal swabs
and here you can see um pretty clearly
that the
they're related to one another as one
would expect one that expects the
they're both oral microbiome
um the the genus this is all shown at
the otu tables here are shown on the
genus level
um and we can see streptococcus rhodia
hemos neisseria and prevotella
make up um at least fifty percent of the
community in both cases
uh in many cases up to 70 75
um whether it's saliva or swabs
however there's still some distinct
differences that you can see
you can see that the the swab have
generally higher levels of streptococcus
while saliva has a higher level of
prevotella
and overall it also looks like saliva
simply picks up somewhat more bacterial
species or genuses than
the suaves do however they're they're
clearly related
um and what's also interesting compared
to what we've generally seen with stool
samples
is that when we do oral microbiome
samples the oral microbiomes are much
more consistent across
individuals than for example something
like a stool sample is
it's much more the same bacterial
species while on in stool samples we
expect
we see much much higher diversity within
the samples
now the next set of samples was all too
interesting these were vaginal swabs
and these showed a completely different
pattern they showed two very strong
clusters
the first cluster was completely
dominated by lactobacillus
and this is completely expected with the
normal vaginal flora
and that's also considered generally the
the healthy
vaginal flora should be dominated by
lactobacillus in order to maintain the
correct environment
and as long as that's also the case it
prevents um
uh infection with other species and
on the other hand the second cluster of
samples we had were nearly completely
dominated by gardnerella
which is a known pathogen and implicated
with bacterial vaginosis
and the the gardenerella in this case
seems to
have been strong infections and so it
nearly completely takes over the sample
we have one sample which is a split
between
lactobacillus and gardnerella and that
could be a
infection that's added to starting or
perhaps clearing and then we have one
more which is also split between the two
samples
again it's lacto lactobacillus at 50
gardnerella at 25
but then the rest is highly diverse and
there's also some indications of this in
the literature
that when the the normal flora is
disrupted
opportunistic bacteria can come in and
settle it and the the
highly diverse um bacterial
community can also be an indication that
something is not quite right
in the sample
now skin swabs showed a distinct pattern
as well
much like the vaginal swabs did however
here we saw the the two distinct
patterns being that though
either the samples were dominated by
staphylococcus which is of course a
known known skin flora
type or they were highly diverse
and it was not the case as in with the
vaginal samples where it was
dominated by a single pathogen in this
case it's a very
diverse sample that shows up in the skin
if it's not dominated by the
staphylococcus
and as i said i wish that we had
either patient data or demographic data
to say something about whether or not
the diverse
sample type here has an effect
on health patterns but it's certainly
interesting to see this pattern simply
that once the cephalococcus is no longer
the dominant species present
it looks like a very diverse set of skin
flora arrives
and then as expected rectal swaps show
us the highest diversity
we see much like with stool samples
we see much more diversity between the
individual samples
it's not as in with the oral microbiome
where we see very much the same
community members
present across all uh all sample types
that we took with only minimal
differences
here it's really highly diverse and
highly individual from
individual to individual but as with
everything else that we've looked at the
species or the genuses that we find here
um are exactly the the ones that we
would expect to see
in a rectal swab their their gut flora
there's some skin ones involved here as
well
but again i think this is also a very
reasonable result
for the rectal swabs and then the last
point here is the
alpha diversity it also showed a very
interesting pattern
where vaginal samples showed
consistently a low diversity
that's exactly what we'd expect after we
look at the data and see that they're
dominated by either the one or the other
genus except for there's i believe one
vaginal sample that is a bit higher and
that's of course the one that had that
highly diverse
uh 25 representation um skin sample is
also
generally a low diversity sample right
with maybe
40 50 different species detected
but with a couple skin samples which had
a higher diversity you can see those
with a steeper curve on the light blue
lines buckle swabs are the next most
diverse sample
um and that was also interesting to see
that the buccal swabs
in general also showed lower diversity
than saliva
saliva showed consistently a higher
diversity
and of course the rectal swabs showed
the highest diversity um and that's also
completely expected
so we were very uh pleased with the
consistency of the results and the the
fact that they all made biological sense
and the beta diversity also confirms the
consistency of the extraction
so here we're showing principal
coordinate scatter plots
on the left hand side it's a two
dimensional one the same data as the
three dimensional one is on the right
hand side
and that's just the limitations of
showing a a three-dimensional plot in
the two-dimensional medium here
but on the on the two-dimensional plot
you i think you can see quite
neatly that the buccal swabs and saliva
samples all cluster together
that they have a similar oral microbiome
type but there are distinct differences
that one can see
buckle swabs are more like buckle swabs
and saliva is like buckle swabs
depending regardless of who the
individual came from
uh rectal swabs are spread out more
which is again what we expect to see
they've just simply based off of the
diversity that we saw
um while skin swabs make their own small
cluster
with some outliers and vaginal swabs
make two distinct clusters whether it's
a
lactobacillus dominated or gardenerella
dominated sample
so again we were pleased with the
consistency of the microbiome extraction
for all of these different sample types
and can recommend the use of the cayenne
power fecal pro kit
for extraction of all different kinds of
human microbiome samples
without preservation
right and so uh we'll end on this note
that um
kaijin really strives to provide
a complete sample to insight solution
for unlocking your microbiome studies
from sample disruption sample
preparation all the way through the
library preparation
ngs and data analysis we strive to
present you with the
the best possible methods
to get the most information out of your
microbiome samples
i'd like to thank you for your attention
and would take
any questions thank you